[Music]
ask that all counselors turned their
microphone off and if they want to speak
on any item they type next or speak in
the chat box
and unmute themselves when I when I come
to them is that Alright
okay so good morning everybody so you'll
have to forgive me I'm going to go from
one screen to the other so you'll see my
profile quite a lot so that's okay and
so welcome counselors to this meeting of
the organisation scrutiny committee this
is a public meeting being streamed live
to YouTube and via the council's website
the meeting is also being recorded for
the purposes of the minutes I've been
advised that the livestream is not up
and running if for any reason the public
can no longer hear or see the meeting
over the livestream we will add gern
until the connection has been be
established can I ask the governor's
officer to explain the procedure for
this meeting please Thank You chair
microphones should remain muted at all
times unless a member has been called on
to speak by the chair this is to
minimize background noise members can
leave their cameras switched on if they
feel that in doing so it enhances the
debate if a member wishes to speak on
another item or during the debate please
indicate this by using the chat function
to type speak a chair will then call on
you to speak as appropriate voting will
be
by acclamation a simple show of hands
will indicate that the community is an
agreement if you are disconnected from
the meeting please try to rejoin as
quickly as possible if you have any
technical difficulties please contact
one of the meeting facilitators as
indicated on the meeting access details
if you're about to speak for meeting
we'll wait a few moments for you to
rejoin thank you
thank you so we'll go straight on to
item 1 which is apologies for absence
please
even a Polish Jew okay have any
counselors presence received approaches
from their colleagues
No so we'll look we'll take a notes
thank you
so those operations will have been noted
okay so
the second item is declarations of
interests if any members do have any
interest to declare can you please turn
your microphone on now and speak on the
interest concerned nope okay item three
of the meetings of the minutes of last
meeting can we agree that the minutes of
the last meeting where a true and
accurate record and it's quite some time
ago if I could see with a show of hands
possibly that you're happy with the
minutes and that they are accurate
yep okay thank you very much
right we go on to item 4 which is to
cover the remit of the committee
obviously some of us had been members of
this committee for over the last year or
more longer than that for some of us and
and we'll know the rm8 but I just asked
sue if you could go through the this
item and specifically we have new
members and I just wonder if they could
be sent a bit of a summary as well by
email happiness I think answer a right
is not present today but it's not been a
member of this committee before and it
might be useful to just have a brief
summary of what this committee is about
so you need to unmute yourself
you
Thank You chair sorry about that yes I
did actually send that out with the
papers terms of reference which I'll
just touch on but I can also send them a
copy of my notes so you can see the
things I'm about to say and apologies to
those members that have been on it
screwed too a long time and we'll know
this but I think it's important both for
new members and also for members of the
public which may be viewing to see what
the committee's powers are so I just
wanted to as I say provide new committee
members with a quick outline of what the
committee can do and the key points of
what schooling is and what it what it
isn't as I say you have your terms of
reference sheet in your agenda pack that
provides details of what is within the
committee's really micked and in that
item item four it gives details of all
the scrutiny committees REME it's the
first bit is about areas that all
scrutiny committees can do and then then
you have the individual bits of each
scrutiny committee so you can see for
organisation screw to committee there's
quite a really MIT to look at all the
surfaces within the council the reason
that provided all of the terms of
reference is that on occasion it may be
that some items cross the limits of more
than one committee so it's so you can
see if ever you have to raise an issue
either by the chair or with myself if it
doesn't fall within this committee there
is a facility for you to ask the chair
of the relevant committee whether they
would consider it at their committee so
just some key points of what scrutiny is
it's a mechanism for backbench
counselors to monitor council
performance and the way it can do this
is by using performance information
monitoring action plans from reviews or
other action plans within the council
and being alert to service performance
on the ground and bringing back to the
chair any issues of concern you might
have about service delivery you can also
examine cabinet
proposals and decisions and you'll see
on the agenda later that aired every
meeting you get a four word plan of
executive decisions this document sets
out what the cabinet will be key
decisions the cabinet will be looking at
over a rolling four month period usually
members have picked up on these things
through other mechanisms but it's
considered best practice to have that
document so you can overview what's
happening at the cabinet in terms of key
decisions and if you do have any issues
you can request some further information
for the committee to to consider whether
they wish to do anything with it you can
contribute to policymaking and review
and you can do this by being a consul
tea monitoring how well a policy is
working and if you think appropriate
making recommendations for improvement
to cabinet as a standard thing scrutiny
is always consulted on whether it wants
to look any poll at any policies in its
remit obviously the council has a lot of
policies because we cover a lot of
service areas so we couldn't possibly
look at them all but if there's anything
that comes through I would raise that
with the chair and ask her whether she
wanted it to come to committee you can
also review issues of concern safe from
residents on behalf of the community and
that's an important part of scrutiny
capturing that public voice you can't
make decisions or right policies
yourself but the power that you do have
is the power of influence and you can
make inform recommendations to cabinet
supported by the evidence which you
gather from a mix of stakeholders
including offices partners and the
public so how does the committee usually
work chair how the committee works is
down to the committee determine itself
but in the past its had two main aspects
that it's done as a committee it
produces an annual work program and this
is where you consider and we'll do this
later on the agenda and the items that
you want to look
in the year and it's good to have a work
program because the committee will be
busy
therefore it's about trying to manage
that workload and fitting that work
program the key issues that you want to
address within the year of course we
also leave some space within that work
program for emerging issues so you can
respond to emergency issues that might
occur say with a service or out in the
community your second piece of work
tends to be review work
so usually committees do an in-depth
review where you select a topic you want
to have an in-depth look at and that
would usually take all the municipal
year to undertake that with you however
given the circumstances we find
ourselves in there is another option
which is called spotlight reviews which
allows a shorter review to take place
and a quicker look at issues so that's
when we come to discuss it later in the
agenda the committee will need to talk
that through and decide what they want
to do if you do an in-depth review that
usually takes all your capacity because
you only have six seven meetings a year
but obviously with a spotlight you might
fit a couple of those in so we'll see
what you think and of course if you have
something that turns up as an emergency
and you've already committed to in-depth
review then the way you could resolve
that you might need to have extra
meetings to deal with an emergency sort
of situation I think the the most
important thing I'd say is that the work
program is a work in progress document
it's not set in stone you need a mix of
activity with room to spare in the year
for those emerging issues that you need
to respond to so you know you'll have a
discussion today and decide the items
you want to put in that work program but
you know you can draft that as you go
along and change things if other things
such more important come up it one of
the things you need to really be clear
is that you consider what you can
actually influence and what values do
choices will add
in terms of the in-depth review work if
I can just mention that Key Stages what
happens in an in-depth review for those
new bear and there's so the committee
will have a discussion about the topics
that you might want to consider and then
you will decide which is the one you're
going to do and you do that by a process
of looking at what might have value you
know what you can influence you know the
sort of it you know the sort of thing
that you think will really be worth
doing in the year because you're going
to invest a lot of time interviewing
people and you know consider doing
documentation stuff like that once
you've selected your topic the review is
then sculpt now in the past this has
usually happened by the chair Vice Chair
myself and the lead officer for the
service that is responsible for the
review topic you've picked and also
potentially the proposer to have an
informal meeting scope the review and
bring it back to the committee this year
some chairs have decided that because of
the nature of virtual meetings that will
do that's scoping within the committee
but again that's with you chair to take
a decision on on what why you'd prefer
to do that once you scope you review
I'll prepare a timetable and project
plan for you for the committee to agree
that you've actually identified you know
the things that you want to look at the
offices and other bodies you might want
to be in touch with and you then begin
your evidence gathering and I'll say you
do this through infuse with stakeholders
possible site visits reviewer
documentation like policies action plans
and performance information then when
you get to the end of the review period
which is usually in a several year then
analyze all that information and from
what you've heard you formulate
recommendations to be included in the
script report which is then submitted to
cabinet for consideration the chair will
then present that report out cabinet and
if they recommend
accepted a lead officer then prepares an
action plan for how those
recommendations will be implemented on
behalf of cabinet so to conclude chair
can I ask the committee at this point if
anyone has any questions following the
briefing nobody sir requested to speak
so thank you sue that was pretty
straightforward and clear and for those
who are very new to this meeting very
often you know as you as we progress
with meetings and none of the
conversation becomes a bit clearer where
what we are trying to achieve is so and
I'm available on the phone as well if
anybody asked questions I'm happy to
have a chat with anybody over the phone
as well to clarify some of the points
that have been made okay so we will move
on to the next item which is the
selection of scrutiny review topic and
if you remember an email was sent out to
members a few weeks ago to see if you
had any suggestions in terms of topics
go with you this year anybody can put
forward suggestions last year were where
well click in 2019 2020 were reviewing
the health and well-being across the
edge char and the stuff of the council
and we've got room for another topic
it's here I do agree with what she said
sue that's a considering went under very
difficult circumstances and we don't
know when we'll be able to I get back
together I like the idea of having a few
spots spotlight topics but obviously
that will depend on what members of this
committee feel they would like to look
into this year but the idea of looking
at one or two topic this year could be a
good solution rather than over looking
something because obviously the logged
I'm paying it has put quite a lot of has
thrown quite a little
unprecedented circumstances and to the
council's the council has not been able
to operate in the same way that it would
have been normally it might be works
that we choose a couple of our spotlight
topics so I'd like to open that to the
floor I don't make you a super first
first whether you received any
suggestions and I've not seen anything
up to now no Travis ed had some
conversations with itself yet and later
in the agenda we'll come back to last
year's review and where yes yes that's
actually in the private session of the
agenda course a corset contouring
changed some staffing yes you and but I
know certainly I think it was the leader
that had suggested mental health and
well-being and whether that might be
worth a look in in you know the
circumstance we find herself in then
home working gathered that the council
is doing some work around this so
whether we are interested in doing
something but obviously if the council's
doing something that would be
duplication but there may be a piece of
work there chair I think you were saying
that if we could add some value to that
that would be something that could be
considered transformation is something
that this committee has a watching brief
on anyhow because we have the council's
transformation program but again given
the circumstances were and you may wish
to do something around that
obviously there's a reflection and what
we've done during the pandemic you know
to look at things that we've been doing
well and whether there's any anything we
can do to help improve that going
forward um and I think I'll leave it at
that
chair for the time being if that's okay
thank you yes so I was just going to say
in terms of them one of the idea that
was put forward which I think it's a
valid ID and I'd like to hear what
members thoughts on that but obviously
during lockdown one of the key issue has
been the health and well-being of our
staff because obviously home working
might sounds great when it comes to a
the flexibility that it offers but
during the circumstances of lockdown how
did we manage that health and well-being
file staff and what are the lessons to
be learned so it could be one of the
spotlight topic that we will look at
because it's very very much something
that is a we're still in log jam as far
as we're concerned but things are being
relaxed so they there's we can see the
end of the of the tunnel so it could be
that we look at that I'd be interested
to see how the council as has managed
that aspect for our staff and going
forward as you said you the council is
looking at again looking at increasing
potentially homeworking
because so a lot of our services and I
see that with all the council a lot of
our services have continued to operate
quite well with a majority of staff
working from home so what it means it
doesn't mean that we should look at
saving all our staff working from home
from now it means that we can look at
ways of offering more flexibility to our
staff but also looking at the the
financial savings that can be achieved
by reducing the number of buildings we
have in terms of owning buildings
renting buildings and maintaining so
there's quite a lot
a positive to it however since the
council is already doing a piece of work
on that as you said so we don't want to
get in their way or duplicate the work
so be we will need to have a
conversation with with a council on what
they're doing and it could be that we
focus purely on how how we manage the
health and well-being of our staff when
they are asked to work from home or they
choose to work from home because again
you might like the idea of working from
home but what is the impact on your
health and well-being I'm interested to
know what members of his committee think
about those two items
yes so we've got a councillor Joe Burke
in want to come and speak
if you would like to promote yourself
you
counselor joking
nope
I don't know where and okay so the next
the next request is from councillor
Maggie Jones
so if you would like to unmute yourself
Maggie
yeah I was thinking about these topics
is things that we need to look at and if
the council are doing stuff about
working from home I think it's good if
we can get people to talk about that
this experience in it so we can gather
all their information about how it's
been for them so we can find out what
the difficulties are now I don't know
whether that's what the council mean
it's going to breathe but I think that
constant to health and well-being like
you said because obviously some people
found it very stressful working from
home being on their own being in
isolation and having to deal with often
public questions that can make you know
I have got some grandeur to this
actually been working from home not from
the council for him an examination board
and she's found it very difficult
because she has been lacking on the
frontline with complaints and things
like that so it's how you deal with
things and you know as the experience of
individuals really yeah thank you come
from Jones one of the issues
of individual members of staff the
office - aisles are ten of us if
required
thank you I think yeah we could have had
a lot of background noise with this that
I got most of the the points that were
made anybody wants to come back on on
those two points unless
I think I think if if for me there's two
to although they interlinked there's two
topics here one is purely the health and
well-being and how we handle that during
lock down and the lessons that can be
learned if a situation like this happens
again
and the second aspect is moving forward
you know in order to to actually
financial saving but also give
flexibility to our staff it's a longer
piece of work mirrors sorry a longer
term piece of work to go to the council
and how do you help with more room
working so I don't know sue it doesn't
seem like to two separate topics that we
could view this way this year and
obviously the second one would be with a
view to help at the review that HR is
already doing
yes chair I think possibly it would help
if I took some further advice through
you with a conversation parts with who's
leading the look at home working within
the castle certainly we could start off
with that first piece of work and then
depending on what comes out of that
conversations decide whether that
becomes the second piece of work where
we add directly to the review that's
taking place or whether we incorporate
it into the first review how does that
sound
yeah that's Anderson is everybody happy
with that I see some heads nodding so
yeah and if I think I think that makes
quite quite a lot of sense when we go
through the draft work program actually
we can see how it all fits together as
well it might make a bit more sense over
the year as we as we go on to the next
item chair can I just check with you
then do you wish to scope within the
meeting at the next meeting or do you
wish to scope scope in an informal group
I think probably the next meeting would
be fine so we all learn yeah because
then it would make it part of our normal
meetings and we've got the next one is
in August isn't it yes yes soon enough
and I would say okay they wear all the
items that really put on a list I
remember last year we went through a
list during a workshop sooo it might be
worse if you send that list again to
members because there were a few ideas
that we kind of discussed already and it
could be that we decided actually one of
the the item that we're on that list
could be the subject of a sports sports
spotlight review if we decide not to go
go ahead with a second one that we've
discussed now if it doesn't fit without
with what the council is doing is that
okay for members yep
okay so we'll move on to the next item
unless you you've got any more comments
to to make on this item sorry yes sir
you're muted sorry chair then yes I'll
just doodle the work on that and bring
it back to the committee and you can see
how it how it looks and decide whether
that's what you procedural yep okay so
we've gone to the next item so which to
consider that the attach draft work
program of the organization scrutiny
committee 2021 and make any suggestions
for items and I know that some of you
have added email again and over has been
emailed again to me so I just gone to my
screen to get back to it um and it gives
you an idea of what we're trying to fit
in during the year and with
specification for each meetings where
we're trying to include each meeting one
comment I would make is obviously the
spotlight on the health and well-being
during lockdown and on this web program
we have interviews which are not shared
on till I think it was November or
December
and nothing if we're doing a spotlight
do it during the logjam play and we need
to have interviews of the staff and the
managers probably earlier so it would be
a useful travel and 50 probably
September I don't know if that makes
sense to you sue yeah Stephanie chair I
mean obviously you've decided you're
going to scope in the meeting so I'll
have to read you get to accommodate yeah
and certainly interviews you know need
to be put back slightly I'll just
mention Chad I don't know whether you
saw it in the chat I do know that in
terms of the working from home item you
were talking about the council has been
doing a survey of staff working from
home seeing how the getting on yet
regards see work program that that's
it's a work in progress chair and what
I'll do after this meeting is work out
all those where things need to fit so
you can see what spare capacity you've
got okay and during the survey that you
mentioned I knew that the the council
we're doing that I think he was
mentioned at some point and do we know
when they're likely to give us some of
the feedback among likely to have that
returned I don't know that she I have
not seen obviously that's something I
can pursue as part of the the scoping
yes I do think that would be handy and I
completed it myself and it was you know
it was a useful document exactly and
like we say we need to avert we can't we
can't be making about own things we need
to use of everything are so variable to
us and that's being done already and and
that would be definitely useful to have
that survey and they're nailing some
like we did last year as some where
stuff interviewed from different
departments and different where we're
differently doing log down yeah chair
can I just just mention then in terms of
the work program you'll see that there's
some items that you've looked at in
previous years and they're there for the
members of the committee to decide
whether you want and stay on not
necessary on the date that they put on
Sonne as an example yet but you have had
the annual report from the head of the
human resources sort of list usually
each year where she covers a number of
things that the council do in support of
staff also you've often received a an
update on the transformation program
from the director for the service the
hicking which of course may be of
interest if they're formulating new
plans for what that transformation
program will look at given yet the panic
that we've just had and that's it yeah
yep so my personal view is that I would
like those items to remain on the work
program I thought they were quite useful
to have last year any members any
comments from the members
no I don't see anybody no so I like I'll
assume that we all agree that those
items should remain on the work program
and certainly the transformer
transformation program because with the
coronavirus curtain on copy 19 issues
the transformation program will be
impacted and no down so we be
interesting to have an in-depth
conversation about that if members are
happy to do that at some points
yep to remind me if any members did have
a suggestions after this meeting we can
still include that because we're coming
back to this work program in August
anyway you're absolutely sure if members
do have any issues they wish to raise if
you can let me have them obviously I'll
have a conversation with the chair and
if they you know it's felt that it's
it's an item for the draft program we'll
work it into the work program obviously
with the review topic you've chose that
will take up many of your dates yeah
we'll just fit it in around that and
they maybe even space for some other
items as we go through yeah okay and
I've been at before I think we all agree
that we'd rather do you know look at an
item in quite and do it properly rather
than trying to look at loads of things
and not doing anything any of those
things were so so so yeah so if any
members have any suggestion that they
think after this meeting that they just
like you feel like you know sort of it
during the meeting you're welcome to
send us an email and let us know what
your thoughts are happy to consider
those okay any questions from members
let me just go to my chat
yes yes I agree so that's good thank you
very much as to any other questions from
members are we happy to move on to the
next item so the next item I've got to
get out of my screen now okay so the
draft wear program we've just gone
through this the next item is a list of
key decisions that we need to consider
so these are the key decisions that the
council's are planning to take I'll just
change my screen again
bear with me
yeah okay
any questions on the key decisions or
comments that you feel you want to make
a disappoint okay I can sort of pops it
I was like yep check and I can I just
make a point I have thrown in the chat
but I do feel I'm not being able to
interact at all because I haven't had
hard copies of this paper word and I'm
not the only counselor here who hasn't
received them so I just wanted that to
be noted I believe they're okay but I
haven't got them so it's making it in
clicks I haven't got another squirrel in
the cycle that's the page and I think
Damon as he has it just send them again
to you counselor Potts but Heather you
can't really get you said given receive
yours either yeah confirmed to members
that there's been no hard copy sent out
at all so no members have got hard
copies but yeah Tyler virtual and a
member feels that they've missed out I
can assure them they have and they're
just not would not sent in the animal
remains been closed
may I comment on that because obviously
I experienced experience of the other
scrutiny committees personally I feel
that chairs and vice chairs at the very
least should have hard copies because
it's very difficult passing between the
two screens this has been raised by all
the committee chairs and I know
certainly one of the other chairs was
going to contact governance to see if
they could get this decision changed I
know obviously one of the reasons I was
given was safety because staff aren't
going into the office to print documents
but hear what the other members are
saying and I think it is difficult from
members to follow without a hard copy so
are gay and I think that's a debate that
needs to be revisited yeah because I
think it has a role at the moment
yeah and Sue can I ask because in
previous years what happened each
members wanted a paper copies they could
regret request it so I suggest that we
we allow members we
members you know if you want to request
a printed copy of the agenda to request
it from the governance would that be
okay sue
it is chair but does it say I did they
have actually taken this decision
because of the pandemic and staff not
being in the office currently to print
it that members aren't being sent hard
copies but I do think that percents of
difficulty so I mean obviously I think
over with the release of lockdown it's
likely that some staff members will go
into the office it will be more limited
because of course you know we need to
keep distancing and stuff so I think if
Damon if you could raise it again with
Nicky and express the comments from
members and we'll see where that takes
us the members have printers would you
be a have to print copies off no okay
will pursue will pursue it with through
governance then chair and I'll come back
to the committee in that you know the
the outcome yeah I breathe mind you yeah
thank you can I bring counselor Joe
Burke in a wanted to speak Thank You
chair one of the difficulties that I've
found women I don't know we get
everywhere these days only sorry one of
the problems attire this is trying to be
able to get the the papers up on a
separate screen I've not worked out how
to do that the oldest slight difficulty
which I just sent a message back to to
counselor pause is that the paperwork
came about two weeks ago so last night I
was panicking came by email sorry do
about two weeks ago so last night I was
panicking wearing me papers and I'd
already printed it off but I'd forgot so
I printed you off when I first got it
and then last night I was just really
checking everything for this morning and
a panic that I've not got the
information and then there it was say
it's about two weeks ago which if you
starting to lose your mind like are most
probably out and then it becomes a bit
difficult to remember that you've
already got it if there was an easy way
to split the screen or something there's
something on my computer laptop the same
screams but I don't know whether that's
I've got my council papers upon that's
how to do it to me
yeah musically I plug for a sound
because my laptop sound you know as I
said before you're all very discreet so
although two machines open at the moment
I still can't see anything other than
what happened self can I just say
because we're going completely we're
very off this meeting this is a
governance governance issue and well I
do appreciate we all having some trouble
it could be sorted afterwards with
governance if that's okay so councillor
more pots you wanted to speak was the
completion of the paperwork or yeah
that's absolutely fine yes yeah we try
so what we live it with sue she's she's
offered to have a chat with governance
and we'll try and sort it out for next
meeting between now and the 4th of
August I'm sure we can sort something
out and it could be that the camps was
able to ask for a printed copy by then
anyway but sue will let us know by email
out she's she's got on one tear
yes thank you okay so we'll go back to
the item on the agenda which is the
forward plan or key decisions and I
appreciate as some of you won't have had
a chance to have a look at them if if
you're not seeing them or you don't have
them on your screen but those of you
worker web cups we've had the chance to
have a look at there is there anything
on there that you wanted to comment on
I'm happy to go through the the go
heading the headings of the items so for
example the first one is land sales to
consider offer offers to sell Castle
owned general from land land at the gate
of the decision was 9 April 2020
geremy Kenyon was responsible portfolio
holder
the next item is a medium term financial
plan to update members regarding the
current position and to agree the
process of securing financial savings
whilst maintaining service delivery
together with any implications which may
have for the counselor staffing
establishment and that decision was made
on the 9th of April 2020 so although
it's called the forward plan it is
decisions have been made already a
vehicle replacement I did have a
question on that actually sue members
are happy with that the vehicle
replacement kept a portfolio holder is
Charlotte castle Charlotte's and cancel
of Charlotte Cupid oh yes this is
something to speak screen on my iPhone
apologies for that is on two screens and
it's a program program of replacement of
to refuse collection vehicles and my
question was is there any add Knox in
the decision so I commonly comment on
the actual decision but as an intention
of looking at placing those with the
electrical vehicles because obviously
that would fit with their local plan
counselor Carrie I can see your mouth
moving back on here you if you want to
unmute yourself
no I was only commenting I didn't know
whether an electric vehicle had the
capability to perform them before
almonds I don't know it's early doors as
I say it's very difficult I've only got
two tablet I haven't gotten built as
well so you know it's getting
documentation but you've already covered
that but yeah I'm with you I'll get to
enjoy it chair may I may I comment who
is speaking
it's Superman oh so yes okay yes and
this this list is if members information
it is a rolling list so it's probably
terrible but it tends to cover a four
month period and sometimes it will have
a date where the decision was due to be
made that doesn't lessen mean it has
been made oh and or and also in terms of
refuse collection vehicles that tends to
come under the community Security
Committee because they monitor the
delivery of the street scene and now
certainly they've had a report on some
vehicles that are going to be purchased
but I'm sure we can get an answer for
the committee from the officer as to
whether the electric has been considered
DubLi a vague recollection that that was
part of the discussion but I think there
may have been some reasons why that was
appropriate in some situations and not
others but I'll get a response for you
yeah and that would be sent to about two
members via email want it oh yeah me
okay yeah and what would be useful
actually on that is because you did say
that the dates of decisions doesn't mean
that it will have been made at the at
that time what will be useful is to you
to know whether the decision has been
made or not councilor Heather liggett's
is next to speak I'm not I'm not
actually a hundred percent positive but
I think it has been put on hold because
as councilor linking suggested the
electric bin lorries
I don't think can travel the distances
we we have in this county etc you know
from our been lawyers has to come from
bowls over at this end because it's so
far from acting too and also I think
there was an astronomical price
difference and in hundreds of thousands
of pounds price difference so I think it
has been put on hold on okay
okay well that's useful information
actually okay and in it so the next item
on that list is a medium term financial
plan to update members regarding the
current position and to agreed a process
for safe you know I've already read that
one it's counselor for parking portfolio
holder apologies about that so with any
comments or questions on this item no
don't angle we've got to counselor more
pots next to speak yeah the item on land
sales can anybody tell me is there a
list that's accessible to the public of
areas of land that are up for sale and
is there sort of any defining as it is
it depended upon area is it certain
areas the areas of areas that are
selected for sales of certain size as a
blank is this information publicly
available I think we can ask the
question but I'd be very surprised if it
was a public documents and the reason is
is sometimes we might have a piece of
land that you consider surplus but you
might not want to put it on the market
just yet so it's only the same as a
developer might want to keep to keep
some of his land back for bit and decide
that they will put it on the market when
it's more valuable when it comes to the
market value has increased so I'd be
very surprised if the council would have
a systematic list that is made public
yeah
the only reason I ask is when we do get
applications to purchase the land and
are you saying that they are just
speculative from the residents point of
view there haven't been able to access
the as you say you think that will be
confidential so they've just actually
contacted the council then I assume and
said would you be interested in selling
this piece of land chair may I add to
that yep yep - the item is just shown
Aslan sells and it's a standing item on
this document this document is a public
document and when it concerns an actual
application that's going through off
from details were shown on there so
people can see what area's being talked
about there is a process within the
council and we have a special committee
that looks at these issues and if I
remember correctly there are obviously
speculative inquiries from members of
the public but there's a procedure that
has gone through the appropriate
committee and being approved for how the
council then looked at them and takes
them forward it used to be
grant Galloway who looked after that
process but obviously he's now gone
controls over but there is definitely
process in place to make sure that you
know it's considered with all the things
that might surround the decision on
whether you sell land or not either at
the instigation of a member suggestion
or cabinet suggestion or an inquiry from
the public
I mean if you want chair can get asked
whether you know if you want any further
information on the process and certainly
get that I know we do have a disposal of
assets procedure which is one of the
documents I know they consider would
that be of interest you can see what
yeah
you
yes it would thank you yeah thank you so
we'll app that send by email as well and
if you could send it to all members
that'd be fantastic
yes chap lovely thank you any other
questions or comments on this item
now so we'll move on to the next item
which if I'm not mistaken it is item 8
additional urgent items we've got
exclusion of the public so I will now
move that the public be excluded from
the meeting that the public be excluded
from the meeting during the discussion
of the following items of business to
avoid the disclosure to them of exempt
information as defined in paragraph 1
part 1